my channel is sponsored by manscaped
which means we'll have an ad from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are going to
catch up on the star wars jedi survivor
official revealed teaser trailer i'm
watching this on ign and of course this
came out of celebration which is
happening
in uh anaheim i believe right now uh
before we get any further into this
video i just want to address my face
because if i don't i know i'll just get
a bunch of comments about it
i just had surgery this week so i have a
very bruised face
um i have to wear this head thing
um
i'm fine it just looks like a lot and my
face is very swollen and it also hurts
if i raise my eyebrows too much so
uh probably won't be that expressive
if you want more details about what the
surgery was i did upload a video on my
um my new channel explaining all of that
so for those who are interested i'll
leave a link in the description if not
i am a-okay
i just am aware that i look like someone
beat the [ __ ] out of me
technically a surgeon um okay so i'm
very excited about this trailer it's
only a minute 23 seconds pretty short
expecting it to look very pretty
let's do it
[Music]
tell me
that's
[Music]
oh my god that looks good why
when you can't
win
what is your next
what is all that
if somebody's drowned or is that like uh
oh my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
2023
i
mostly
just blown away by how pretty that was
that was nuts
damn
see what the people think shall we
this is where the fun begins that's a
reference to hayden christensen
i'm not a star wars fan but this game
changes everything for me finished the
first game a few months ago when they
ran the storyline through not looking
for 100 achievements still great cool
yeah strange thing that'd be uploaded
that far
super excited to deserve the sequel i'm
just hoping customization is better as
opposed to just ship skins and different
colored ponchos i agree with that would
be nice to have some more customization
this was epic love the first game this
one promises to be even better well i
don't know about that we barely saw
anything
fall in order was the first game since
my childhood that really intrigued me in
playing more and more i'm so hyped for
this one
all very positive
glad that continuing with the story of
cal looks like he may be going solo for
a while but i'd love to see the old
cross show up
yeah silverblade said we only need three
things a fast travel system for clear
areas while backtracking while it does
do metroidvania stuff like you unlock
areas in the first game
if you're going back there a lot to try
to get 100 which actually like a lot of
people seem to have done
i would agree with that
a couple of missions that get cal out of
the wild and into civilization also very
nice but very difficult to do because of
hardware um
it's very difficult for video games to
manage cities at this point i'll get
there eventually but right now we don't
really have the ability to do that to a
satisfying extent
uh three dynamic lightsaber effects and
damage don't give us the taser stick
again yeah i agree with that it also is
interesting that in this trailer
if i saw it correctly they've repaired
cal's lightsaber
which is also interesting because it in
theory is dual
it is time to talk about manscaped and
today we are talking about a cause that
i try to get behind every year which is
saving balls
did you know that every hour every day
one man is diagnosed with testicular
cancer in fact it is the most common
cancer for men age 15 to 35. april was
national testicular cancer awareness
month and again this is something
i try to talk about every single year
because i think it is very important to
talk about men's health issues and kind
of get rid of the stigma of talking
about it so that people are paying more
attention
to their balls so with men's health and
hygiene in mind
manscaped has partnered with the
testicular cancer society to help you
take care down there isn't this cool
while you are taking care of yourself
with something like the ultra smooth
package manscaped and the testicular
cancer society want to remind you to
check yourself at testicular cancer with
easy once a month routine at home self
checks so for a limited time to remind
men to actually look after themselves
you can now get manscaped limited
edition the tcs special edition
lawnmower 4.0 there are only 10 000
units of this beautiful thing in
existence this is my favorite color
purple if you would like to purchase the
new special edition lawnmower 4.0 purple
trimmer visit manscape.com tcs where
they also have information on how you
can perform your at-home self-checks
plus as part of this manscaped is
donating 50 000
to the testicular cancer society to help
those diagnosed with testicular cancer
which is just
the coolest if you want to donate
yourself you can also do so of course at
testicularcancersociety.org i highly
encourage you to do so links will be in
the description of both of these things
and as always you can use my promo code
alana 20 for 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com join the manscape movement
and don't forget to take care of your
pet now back to the video um in any case
it looks beautiful i believe this game
is being made on unreal engine 5
and i
am yet to stop being ridiculously hyped
about unreal 5 and what it's going to do
for video games and how awesome they're
going to look so that is super exciting
um
not much else to say it looks cool i'm
glad that it exists i look forward to
playing it um
yeah cameron who's the lead is a friend
of mine and he's wonderful and
it looks good um while we're here
because that is like pretty short and
didn't have too much me to take away
from it i also wanted to see the andor
trailer let me go find that real quick
okay this is the trailer for and or
disney plus teaser trailer hd star wars
series it's what this is titled us
uh this is disney plush show let's have
a look
okay
interesting
that's cool
huh
they're so proud of themselves
so fat and satisfied
i like the tone of this so far
the vibes are good everywhere
they're watching me now
[Music]
soon enough these days will end
there will be no rules going forward
it's gonna be like a heist
[Applause]
people
are standing up
what a weird dialogue i'm going to die
that much
that's what a reckoning sounds like
very
pretty very pretty
oh all the study first there you go
they are pumping them out let's check
out the comments on this one okay
trailer looks like it's for a movie i
also love that we finally get to see a
glimpse of the imperial senate for the
first time agreed it looks like a movie
this is probably one of the disney plus
um
saga's best trailers in terms of
quality like even obi-wan which i have
watched and we'll have a video about
impressions later
um
has pots where it looks cheap or empty
this does not i'm definitely in
agreement with that it'd look like a
movie
very cool finally a star wars action
series that are not set in the desert
i agree it sucks so bad i'm so sick of
[ __ ] tatooine
anyone who's watched narcos mexico knows
diego luna can definitely carry a show
all by himself
i really like diego luna
the show is important because cassian
andor is where the ewoks come from looks
like some of the best star wars world
building i've seen in a trailer yet that
has nothing to do with jedi and
absolutely all for it i think that's a
bit hyperbolic but i am in agreement
that
i don't feel like all the star wars
stuff should have to tie to the
skywalkers or to the original trilogy
the universe is so big there are so many
things going on why can't we branch out
like they shouldn't have anything to do
we don't need to have jedi we don't need
to have the same villains like get it
out of that world it's so expensive why
would you not take advantage of that
expense
i love when trailers open with music
like this and wait until the build up to
add lines from the movie
teaser trailer so i'd expect the trailer
to hear this the audio in the trailer is
so good agree with that
great trailer and it seems like a great
show again unless you guys have seen
more context than me i don't feel like
it looks like anything
similar to rogue one would be fair
it looks good i like the trailer a lot
yeah again agreed this looks ten times
more cinematic than all previous disney
plus star wars series even kenobi agreed
maybe it was something like they've
taken the criticism and finally i've
been like okay we have to make sure that
our our shows look just as good as our
films because star wars did start as a
film franchise so that expectation is
there that the star wars now has a look
because it started as movies it has a
look that regardless of the format
you're like oh that's star wars i
identify that as star wars based on how
it looks so when you change that or
scale it down and make it cheaper it
doesn't feel like star wars anymore um
at least i've definitely had that
experience
looks pretty solid i really like the
idea of following mon mothmas he tries
to be both a rebel and a senator should
be some fun political intrigue i'm sure
that uh george lucas would appreciate
[Laughter]
that very cool this is a great trailer
yeah
definitely uh enjoyed it
um so yeah i basically just wanted to
catch up on
those two both of which look awesome to
me of course i did not go to celebration
um because of the whole surgery
situation i didn't feel like i would be
down for that
but a lot of cool announcements have
come out for it we still got two more
days so we might get some more exciting
stuff these were the big two that i
really wanted to check out
and they both look super cool
they both look super cool you'd love to
see it